[Musik]
hallöchen lieben heute gibt's das
besondere video nämlich die beide am
torte oder auch auf arabisch
ich habe es immer noch nicht gelernt
dieser buchstabe im arabischen einheit
und könnte ich kann ich lese ich kann es
nicht ich kann es nicht meint meine hals
ist nicht mein daumen ist nicht gemacht
dafür immer ich kann es nicht
und gott ich sag einfach auf kate orte
so auf jeden fall ist ja ist ja bald der
monat ramadan zu ende und anschließend
wird das ramadanfest gefeiert und dann
mache ich ja jedes jahr eine hübsche
torte für alle die einfach gerne mal was
besonderes backen möchte und ich fange
jetzt auch direkt an ich habe das video
jetzt so ein bisschen also das rezept
ist ein bisschen einfach gestalte ich
möchte auch dass jetzt nach macht ich
habe sie zuallererst eine meiner
lieblings krebs die ich gleich noch mit
zwei besonderen zutaten aufpimpen werde
hier habe ich meinen schlagsahne in der
rührschüssel die es ganz kalt und da
gebe ich jetzt quark und doppel ram
frischkäse das zu den doppeln frischkäse
könntet ihr auch ersetzen durch
magerquark 8 durch magerquark durch oder
mascarpone mascarpone ist euch
überlassen also ob er jetzt doppel
rahmenfrist oder mascarpone lag aber
wichtig ist halt die zwei zutaten sind
sehr fest und die braucht ihr schon für
die creme aber mark medlock hat das noch
mal so ein bisschen auch soll ich mal
jetzt folgen das ich gebe einfach alles
in die röhre stellt zusammen mit
puderzucker und vanille extrakt und dann
fange ich an das erst langsam und dann
immer schneller werdend aufzuschlagen
so dass es krank so puderzucker für die
süße vanille extrakt für den geschmack
so und jetzt erstmal langsam damit es
nicht alles überschwemmt und dann immer
schneller werden verrühren
so oder ganz einfach den spritzschutz
der auch schlau und dann kann auch
nichts mehr passieren so floß
[Musik]
nach weniger als zwei minuten ist die
creme soweit fertig doch sehr sehr
flüssig und sie wird auch im kühlschrank
fest
ich habe am ende des habt ihr gesehen
ein bisschen sahne fest einrieseln
lassen das hilft einfach das dann im
kühlschrank auch noch stabiler wird das
empfehle ich euch auch so und die jetzt
gebe ich noch frische früchte rein
jetzt haben wir gerade erdbeersaison und
ramadan zusammen daher unbedingt
ausnutzen hier wert werden die habe ich
jetzt hier geführt wird die gebe ich
jetzt mit zu creme was ich auch mache
die idee kamen gerade ich gebe die diese
logos kekse reihen das sind diese
spekulation karamell kekse also wenn ihr
geht's nicht habt und butterkekse hin
dann würde ich jetzt euch ganz leicht
davon abraten
das stelle ich mir wiederum nicht sehr
lecker vor aber geschmäcker sind ja auch
verschieben
aber die passen auch mit renault
zusammen davon gebe ich jetzt auch so ja
so ein bisschen einfach nach gefühl zwei
esslöffel reichen schon
[Musik]
so die creme ist fertig das ging auch
recht schnell ihr habt selber gesehen
auch sehr sehr unkompliziert und jetzt
habe ich hier meine bizkit böden ihr
wisst ich bin kein fan von endlos langen
videos deswegen habe ich die show
vorbereitet und ich habe ja auch ein
basic videos ist das video ist bug
schule da habe ich euch ja gezeigt wie
das funktioniert und ich werde euch auch
die ganz genauen mengenangaben zu allem
in die video beschreibung schreiben auch
zu denen bizkit böden die ich genommen
habe ich durch die backzeit
reinschreiben so dass er es ganz easy
nachmachen können ich habe heute so
gemacht ich möchte nämlich für meinen
die seine sehr hohe torte haben und da
bist hier meinen bis geboten aufgeteilt
in 2 18 cm torten ringen und dann backt
auch gleichmäßig als wenn ihr jetzt die
masse einmal komplett reinfeldt wird
oben trocken und ihnen vielleicht nicht
gab daher das als tipp am rande das löse
ich die einmal diesen auch schön
abgedrückt abgekühlt genau man merkte
ich faste ich bin noch nicht ganz da das
entferne ich hier einmal den tortenring
und anschließend werde ich jeden boden
einmal durchschneiden ich habe jetzt ja
auch noch ein extra tipp für euch wenn
ihr ich möchte dass die böden heroben
austrocknen dann nehmt ihr euch einfach
ein küchentuch einmal unter wasser
halten ausbringen und dann an die
oberfläche link und dann tropft euch
nichts mehr aus es wirklich beeinflusst
ist und alle anderen das kannte ich doch
schon
[Musik]
so als nächstes kommt einfach der teil
in dem ihr alle schichten ihr habt
gesehen dass ich meine böden relativ
dick eingeteilt habe ich möchte eine
hohe torte und bei bizkit böden ist es
so der ist so software ist einfach so
soft dass ihr diesen dicken boden dass
es nicht das wirkt nicht sooo
schwebebahn ist sich so dass ihre wochen
nur boden habt sondern das boden creme
verhältnis ist perfekt und die böden
sind sehr sehr zahlreiche menschen durch
ich beschwere mich ja das ist und weil
es so und jetzt ja ich habe jetzt hier
ein konstrukt haben so hat dieses wort
aber es ist ein konstrukt ist jung aber
das konstrukt ist diesmal anders ich
nämlich keine torte hamza ein neues
konto ich habe einfach mal drehbare
tortenplatte habe ich im jackpot
untendrunter meinen ersten boden und
jetzt kommt meine meinen mann xxl
tortenring immer wenn ich faste sind die
videos da komme ich mal so viel trüber
schön
ich bin in wahrheit nicht verwirrt nein
so ich legte jetzt einmal drumherum
schön entspannen so und so dafür ist ein
klemm hebel da sonst rutscht da wieder
raus so und jetzt hab ich einfach an zu
schichten und ich mache jetzt ich werde
den boden auch nicht trinken weil die
creme enthält genug feuchtigkeit und
wenn das dann im kühlschrank kühlt dann
zieht die feuchtigkeit noch mal in die
böden ein und dann habt ihr noch
software das ergebnis software is
ergebnis
[Musik]
und das ist das was ich meine für solche
momente für diesen augenblick habe ich
meine xxl winkel palette produzieren
lassen erfunden sage ich mal weil so
gibt es ja auch noch gar nicht auf dem
markt und da saßen wir echt lange daran
wir haben an alles gedacht materialdicke
ob es nach vorne hin komisch ist oder
nicht aufs vorne spitz ist oder rund die
länge der griff alles ist alles durch
dachte ich verlinke sie euch in die
infobox genauso wie alle anderen
produkte die ich benutze so jetzt
streiche ich das ganz einfach glatt
[Musik]
so oben angekommen könnt ihr entweder
die spezial palette 2.0 nehmen oder er
schnappt euch die streich palette das
geht natürlich auch und ich fühl mich
hat so ein bisschen make up artist mitte
die komplette palette
ich habe 2.0 also weiß ich nicht ja also
ich sehe den bug bereich gibt es auch so
einiges so und concealer kämpfte
highlight also ist das kennst du schon
mal nicht schlecht so und jetzt gebe ich
euch noch ein tipp den abschluss macht
ihr am besten mit dem boden also dass
ihr sohn gerade abschluss hafner und
nicht die ungerade seite oben wobei die
böden sind schon sehr gerade durch das
schneiden aber es ist immer noch so ein
extra tipp beim backen dass man den
boden ganz oben
nach vorne drauf gibt so und jetzt mache
ich es so ich hab mir buttercreme
vorbereitet auch dazu gibt es ein basic
rezept und ich werde jetzt die
oberfläche ganz dünn mit buttercreme
einstreichen das video in der infobox
verlinkt einfach aus dem grund damit sie
nicht austrocknen
damit ihr damit geschützt ist und danach
gebe es für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
so die torte konnte schön durch kühn und
jetzt brauchen wir irgendwas zur
stabilisation ihr wisst ja dass wenn
torten sehr hoch sind sie zum kippen
neigen können das klingt jetzt
dramatischer als es ist hier so torten
röhren zu uns stabilisieren
die nämlich eigentlich wenn ich
zweistöckige torten mache aber ich bin
ganz ehrlich die braucht ja eigentlich
nicht ihr könnt auch schaschlikspieß
hinnehmen ganz einfache schaschlikspieß
aber ich habe keine mehr da deswegen
nehme ich jetzt die und steckt drei
stück davon rheine müssen auch nicht
perfekt abgeschnitten werden weil wie
gesagt es kommt ja keine zweite etage
oben drauf deswegen machen wir es nur zu
stabilisieren
[Musik]
ich fordere dich zum kampf auf offen gab
also als nächstes werden wir mit meinem
xxl tortenring messer im tortenring
entfernt ihr wisst ja ich stand vor
diesem problem mit meinem volk layer
cake da habe ich auch eine hohe tempo
und ich liebe rothorn ich stand vor dem
problem dass ich die torte nicht aus dem
tortenring befreien konnte wie schlimm
ist dass wenn ihr alles bisschen macht
man denkt okay
wie kriege ich jetzt raus ohne dass sie
mir einen seiten bricht oder reiste
dafür habe ich meine ich sie es eher
trocken tortenring messer entwickelt und
wird das jetzt lösen ist ein wohl das
ist eine neuheit will also also das kann
man jetzt auch als werbung deklarieren
aber ich glaube ihr seid mir nicht böse
das ist ja ein eigenes produkt so jetzt
einmal mit der dünnen klinge rein die
andere seite hält das noch mal fest dann
einmal entgegen
und ihr habt gesagt dies sei nicht so
bescheiden das ding gibt echt nirgends
seit meine idee
ich habe das problem erkannt und
deswegen muss man schon sagen das ist
schon echt geiles produkt es gibt doch
nur bei uns wir sind wir sind die vacher
genau googelt ist die welt ist nicht für
die welt das auch bei uns finden und das
ist ja das schöne ich verlinke euch
definitiv in den info box und jetzt
lösen wir einfach mal einen tortenring
was wir dann machen ganz einfach
komplett einstreichen mit buttercreme
macht euch keinen stress wir werden das
dann macht ihr noch mal einen streich
ist also nicht ganz so ordentlich sein
noch steht alles
so die torte habe ich jetzt grob
eingestrichen sie tauchen gar nicht
schön aus aber ich mache mir jetzt
keinen druck weil gleich wird es eben
noch mal richtig ordentlich verstrichen
jetzt muss die äußere buttercreme
schicht fest werden dass dort so
ungefähr 20 25 oder maximal 30 minuten
je nachdem wie kein kühlschrank
eingestellt ist und dann kommt das
besondere und darauf freue ich mich und
bin schon sehr gespannt und ich hoffe es
klappt alles also bis gleich jetzt ist
die äußere buttercreme schicht fest und
wir können weitermachen ab jetzt wird
sehr spannend
also ich möchte jetzt wieder das motiv
der mondsichel aufgreifen das ist ja das
symbolische motive in ramadan und dafür
nimmt ihr euch jetzt einen ausstecher
oder ein glas eine schüssel irgendwas
rundes und zeichnet euch das volk und
das ist einfacher wenn man das mit was
runde macht ich zeige euch das jetzt und
dann geben wir stellen nicht sträuße
dann gehen wir eher butter kleben und
dann streusel drauf
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich das einmal kühlen
lassen für zehn minuten damit auch hier
die streusel richtig schön festsitzen
so und jetzt werde ich den rest meiner
buttercreme färben wir haben wir
diskutiert welche farbe lila oder blau
ich glaube wie dem blauen in dem blau
genau gebe ich einfach ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe reihen verrührt das
und dann trage ich das einmal rundherum
auf und dann müsst ihr natürlich hier
darauf aufpassen dass er die mondsichel
schön nach vorne könnt euch auch einen
spritzbeutel dafür nehme ich doch das
mache ich auch
[Musik]
so beim einstreichen müsst ihr euch viel
zeit nehmen macht das ordentlich immer
wieder hin und her schieben die
buttercreme es ist ein bisschen tricky
bei der mond sicher alles andere geht ja
total einfach und ansonsten würde ich
euch meinen tipp geben kühlt das nochmal
ordentlich und wenn ihr mögt streich den
rand der mondsichel nochmal mit
lebensmittelfarbe ein also noch mal es
gibt noch mal so einen schönen touch das
habe ich auch bei meinem ersten voll
kleingeld gemacht und ich finde das
macht das ganze einfach komplett so was
ich dann mache ich nehme mein gold spray
und sprühe nochmal ordentlich drauf das
gibt auch noch mal sehr sehr schönen
effekt ich weiß nicht ob durch die
kamera so rüberkommt aber es sieht echt
sehr beeindruckend aus und ja dann fehlt
ja eigentlich noch die oberfläche und da
habe ich mir überlegt ich muss ja jetzt
nicht noch mehr in die höhe ziehen mit
ihrem ich einen tupfer sondern ich nehme
ganz einfach früchte frische früchte die
passen einfach immer und dann könnt ihr
sie eigentlich auch schon sofort
servieren
und es ist einfach fast festliches das
ist einfach fest ich ihnen sehr frisch
sehr locker
natürlich habt ja auch die buttercreme
aber es ist ein gutes zusammenleben
du bist heute ein optischer hingucker
definitiv wir können das ganze jetzt
nach machen schritt für schritt
ja es ist auch schon langsam dunkel und
gleich ist ist da also gleich dürfen war
auch das fasten brechen
ansonsten wünsche ich euch auch einen
wunderschönen tag hinterlasst diesem
video ein bisschen nach oben wenn ich
nicht schon längst getan habt abonniert
main kanal kostenlos natürlich und dann
sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten videos
eure kritik
[Musik]